oh my God right Ryan's dead he's dead
are you okay wait oh my God
is he alive kiss him on the lips
[Music]
okay this just happened this is a
[__] this is one of those stories
where it's like oh my God I'm so glad
this happened while we were at JK
so I'm gonna play a video I'm gonna play
a video for you guys and if you guys are
gonna tell me what you think so this are
you covering your face right what's
happened
that's all bad stupid
I call the world we call police when she
came home to find her house trashed
this is what they found on our
surveillance tape crashing sound
[__] you dude why are we even
breaking sound oh no how's the bear even
up there I don't [__] see [__] dude
I don't see anything oh it's
you gotta see what happens with this
video
I kind of feel a little bit inspired
right now oh
playing piano
joint rate the freezer wow thank God for
these captions so yeah so it's the
Washington Post that's how you know it's
official democracy dies in diamonds
so yeah there was a this is breaking
news breaking news is a Hot Topic
oh my God right Ryan's dead he's dead
are you okay wait oh my God
is he alive kiss him on the lips
CPR on the dick all right guys
[Applause]
I can't figure off this man that's how
dead I am from you doing this what did I
do what did I do you know what you did
what did I do yeah that was the most
gangster [__] I've ever seen holy [__]
dude those album boxes are expensive so
[__] gangster what the [__] that was
so cool okay guys turn that into a short
check that out no no I'm not I refuse
did Ryan's so mad at me I can't believe
it why are you mad at him what's the
real news
bear broken it's really doing the bear
article holy [__] dude all steam day
guys I thought we did this one already
no no he kept sending chat saying
cause breaking news
dude
weeks ago it was the last block where
you weren't hosting I don't think that's
what happened and then you sent this to
the group chat saying hey guys can you
Hot Topic this this is important for you
and it showed up exactly the same
Wayward all you saw was this camera yeah
and we all were like oh what the [__] is
this bear comes in and then you check
the date and even that's an old article
I don't know this this is breaking news
why do you want to talk about this
article this is a Hot Topic
we got rush it out though let's do it
all right go ahead give it your best
shot okay so yeah there's no this bear
comes he's like you know he comes to the
door and then this bear like starts
playing the piano it's [__] crazy and
this these homeowners like holy [__]
[__] you know we can't believe this
Bear's playing this piano he didn't look
like it trashed the house I think
they're just being racist yeah exactly
and they're like I can't believe this
Bear's playing a baby baby grand piano
like shouldn't babies be playing baby
game not Bears yeah and so that freaked
people out yeah and so yeah naturally it
just it just takes your natural
auspicions you have you have your own
prejudices right we all do yeah we all
do this babies
yeah no no helping you let him let him
support it on his own
dude like I'm trying to listen and be
and I'm running out of bandwidth
I think we all are dude
this doesn't sound like an end of the
day right
[Laughter]
we got it no because it I'm dying to
because he's like remember the yesterday
he goes oh dude I gotta have that many
articles at least one would be that yeah
dude we're split
I was like no dude you got the whole day
tomorrow oh [__]
he's gonna [__] with us what was the
other one you were gonna use besides
this one was there another one this one
no this is the one this is the one there
was another there wasn't another article
that you had yeah Steve for sure
yesterday was like Yo dude you got the
whole day holy [__]
he's like now you're [__] with me
right
no no this is it how old was the bear
how old was the bear I don't know but
the Bears [__] five years older now
in barrier and barrier yeah
35 .
and barriers do you have any pictures of
the Bears friends
yeah
was it a Steinway was it a Yamaha you
gotta love it when the owners even hate
this room
hey um what was the bear's birthday
all right now riff
Once you pull that up I just knew
instantly because I just remember
staring at it for so long after the
first time and it because it was slow to
load it was like I was like oh what is
this video that like yeah it's gonna be
good Steve doesn't normally send things
and goes hey guys make sure this is like
I was like it must be good and it's like
this a bear playing piano
2017. it doesn't usually send stuff
that's real
he says this is not a costume this is
real unlike you you said the wolf
costume some [__] did I jerk it off as
wolf
[Laughter]
do I like [__] get this jollies or
whatever and you like you enjoyed that I
guess that was Hot Topic guys yeah yeah
that was HT maybe that was actually a
Hot Topic that was a viral okay that's
gonna save this company you're bringing
up this 2017 [__] we're going down you
enjoyed that many times when I see like
wild animals like that I go why can't I
I be a rich Saudi Prince so you own one
I I want a bear I want a saber-toothed
[__] tiger I want a wolf costume dude
I want a Japanese man and a in a Lassie
Collie costume Sabertooth Tiger's
extinct or no can you you can still buy
those right uh at the at the Museum
oh right like in Taxidermy style have
you guys seen that that video that was
going viral of um I think they're like
the Middle East somewhere or like maybe
Russia and I sent this video to to
Anthony uh-oh and it was a guy a very
small like like a dwarf man and there's
a bunch of lions right there yeah and
they pick up this dwarf man and they
throw it to the lion he doesn't lion
doesn't like eat them or anything that's
Anthony's favorite kind of the guy's
just like ah we should react to that
maybe since we're on an animal oh they
don't even
heard him nah they just like try to bite
him a little bit and just screaming it's
kind of they're just trying to bite him
a little God what the [__] how much do
you think do you think would cost to
make a saber tooth out of paper mache
to make us like not a lot too but it's
paper mache though what is that's not
like 40 bucks yeah it's one step below
fiberglass paper machine this is
newspaper and fun coating can we glue
that to a tiger and make like a [__]
billion dollars
oh yeah because dude you just need a
horn he wants to just you want to just
paper mache the saber tooth and then
take the teeth
that's even cheaper find a type of hot
glue some paper mache favorite team I
should date the tiger you hot glue it it
wakes up the tranquilizer is gonna cost
more than the paper mache it's fine
because back in the day they would put a
horn on a horse and be like this is your
one chance to buy a unicorn and then
[__] suckers like me yeah in medieval
times would buy and I bring it home be
like father look I've bought a unicorn
and then they'll be like what the [__]
[__] where's the bread oh don't worry
father it came with these magic beans
oh oh dear it's just a Peapod what have
I done oops where's the bread
please subscribe to our patreon oh my
God so true yeah so we should plug the
patreon can't wait to actually do real
news and real jokes over there dig into
hard news journalism
in
2023. we're gonna have Steve on the
field out there I'm gonna be out there
the real questions and making sure that
we have the photos that nixo is asking
for deep diving
please yes I'll be asking the questions
everyone wants to know like hey so like
I heard a molestation happen here like
what exactly happened can you exactly
explained
step by step what happened the
sensitivity in that hey I heard them all
Station Avenue yeah hey wait I'm kicking
this cable this Cable's [__] breaking
my balls hold on yeah hey so like I
heard somebody die today yeah what
happened how are you related
were you close who got touched you you
look like it was you
wasn't a good death a bad death come on
oh my god dude
all steam day's so good done and JK is
gonna be so sick in 2023. yeah I think
so and we're gonna win a streaming
finally dude finally long last because
we're kind of controversial like we're
the only channel that would probably
like that hasn't been out hey that was
like that was one of the top comments
that was one of the top comments on um
on the what what men want is that people
were just like screaming you'll never
see YouTubers make a video like this
ever
yeah that's true
oh boards just exactly talking about how
good he can suck dick
oh that video came out dude yeah it was
a good video I think that should win a
streaming it's a it's a like yeah
can you please imagine you have options
yep
I saw from comments dude you probably
made a lot of dudes [__] cream pants
yeah dude those dudes know that they're
good at sucking dick too they just don't
want to admit it dude the only guy who's
probably not down is Graham Stefan
the only guy
[Music]
oh
foreign